Okay informal writing, you're up.
All right.
Hey everybody, I'm informal writing...
...and I'm much more conversational than our former friend.
Sometimes, I use slang or even figures of speech.
I like to include a more personal or emotional tone.
I also speak directly to you, the audience, by using words like "you" or "your".
I'm pretty simple because I use short sentences...
...or even incomplete sentences to make my point.
Oh lastly, I like to keep it short so I use contractions and abbreviations.
That pretty much wraps up my style of writing, thanks.
Thank you, informal writing.
As you can see, each style has their own merits...
...but their usage depends on the tone you're trying to set.
Think about your audience and the topic of your article.
Adapt a formal style when you're taking on a more serious, objective topic...
...and write informally when you're comfortable and familiar with your readers.
In the end,...
...you have to make the decision of which style of writing is best for your articles.